j'adore Javan merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui merci de m'avoir invité
alors vous avez maintenant la
nationalité française mais vous avez
grandi à Téhéran vous dites je suis une
fille de l'Iran alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez ressenti quand vous avez vu ce
nouveau soulèvement en Iran écouter
c'est une succession de soulèvement à
vrai dire depuis que ce régime
criminel et enfin je dirais est en Iran
depuis 43 ans les Iraniens se sont
soulevés plusieurs fois
et à chaque fois la révolte a été
réprimée dans le sang et cette fois-ci
c'est différent c'est différent parce
que
quand Marsa Amini Marcelina Amélie a été
assassiné ça d'une part sa retournait le
couteau de l'humiliation dans le corps
de tous les Iraniens les femmes et les
hommes et le fait que elle était une
femme jeune pas militante politique
quelqu'un de très très normal qui était
venu visiter le capital et puis avec son
frère elle était jeune femme cure de
sunnite et était assassiné c'est un
assassinat d'État
le pays est en feu
ton nom est sur toutes les lèvres
les femmes brûlent leur voile tu ne peux
pas le savoir puisque tu n'es plus chers
président français cher président
américain vous savez que ce régime est
terroriste et n'a pas à représenter les
rangs
ça va faire vraiment révolter toute la
population parce que tout le monde sait
que ça peut arriver à n'importe qui à
n'importe quelle femme jeune femme qui
se fait arrêter qui se fait réprimander
qui se fait humilier en pleine rue parce
que quelques mèches de cheveux dépassent
de leur voile mais c'est une révolte
quand même qui est menée par des femmes
alors c'est une révolte vous savez qui
est menée par les femmes et par les
hommes pour la première fois peut-être
que les la jeune génération réclame
revendique l'égalité des droits hommes
femmes en Europe
[Musique]
le slogan femme liberté et cette chanson
exactement l'âme iranienne c'est un
peuple qui n'est pas terroriste c'est un
peuple qui ne mérite pas ce régime c'est
un peuple qui n'est pas islamiste en
trois mots c'est le rejet total de
régime islamique de l'islamisme et en
trois mots c'est la revendication de la
démocratie donc la jeune génération
elle ne veut plus du tout de son régime
elle elle veulent pas mourir pour des
droits les plus élémentaires
imaginez une jeune femme se fait
tabasser se fait tuer parce qu'ils ont
ôté leur voile
quand elles enlèvent leur voix quand
elles brûle leur voile qu'est-ce qu'elle
nous disent en fait vous savez le voile
réduit la femme à son corps donc un
objet sexuel et ça lui autres la liberté
de disposer de sa vie ça veut dire une
femme peut devenir un jeune homme
médecin on ira même député mais elle n'a
pas le droit de disposer de sa vie de
décider de sa vie elle reste
éternellement sous la tutelle masculine
comme si elle était une mineure de cinq
six ans et puis le voile je l'écris en
instaure l'aparté sexuelle
l'aparté de sexuelle ça veut dire la
moitié de la population les femmes sont
considérées comme ce fut local les Noirs
aux États-Unis
au moment où il y avait l'apartheid
raciale la moitié de la population n'a
pas droit dès que vous ouvrez la bouche
dès que vous voulez parler on vous dit
cache tes cheveux baisse tes yeux donc
on vous réduit un être ça veut dire
l'humanité des femmes lors ont été
retirés elle pose ses gestes en sachant
qu'elles peuvent mourir pour le faire
donc c'est au péril de leur vie ça
demande beaucoup de courage les jeunes
ils disent on va nous battre on est prêt
à nous battre à mourir pour reprendre
les rangs et il dit sur les réseaux
sociaux quand on quitte la maison le
matin pour libérer l'Iran on n'est pas
sûr que le soir on soit encore vivant ou
qu'on ne soit pas arrêté pour être
torturé et vous vous savez ce que c'est
vous avez été arrêté hein à 13 ans oui
et
j'ai fait une courte période de prison
pour avoir manifesté contre le régime
oui bien sûr devant mon collège oui j'ai
été arrêté vous savez il y a eu des
défis de 10 ans de 11 ans qui ont été
exécutés et à l'époque on affichait même
le nom des gamines assassinés dans le
journal parce que Romani disait la
mauvaise herbe il faut le couper quand
ça n'a pas encore poussé
et moi j'ai eu des amis qui ont été
assassinés avec leurs parents parce que
ils avaient des parents jeunes qui
étaient très politisés très contre le
régime de roméni donc ils ont été même
exécutés et
c'est alors vous ça doit vous faire
quelque chose de particulier quand vous
voyez ces jeunes parce que là on voit
même des écolières quoi comme vous dites
tout jeune manifester tout mon visage a
une espèce eczéma pour vous dire
depuis
et
du matin je me je m'endors avec l'Iran
je rêve toute la nuit de ce qui se passe
là-bas je me réveille avec les reins
est-ce que
[Musique]
Bella
Ciao
[Musique]
et Kimi guère
et qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
l'Occident de pays comme le Canada
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire vous savez
dans une lettre que j'ai écrit à
Emmanuel Macron je lui ai dit le fait
que Poutine
fait des massacres en dehors de ces
frontières et que le régime iranien
massacre sa propre population
mais vous devez pas mettre de différence
entre ces deux criminels parce que
massacrer sa propre population n'est pas
moins criminel que massacré en dehors de
ces frontières donc je ne comprends pas
tant de tergiversesations pourquoi tant
de attendre cette espèce d'attentisme
des dirigeants occidentaux pour imposer
les mêmes sanctions au régime iranien
que Monsieur Poutine et ses proches
et le soutien qu'on peut apporter aux
iraniennes on a vu des actrices par
exemple se couper une mèche de cheveux
ça c'est important écoutez les actes
symboliques sont importants ont eu leur
importance pour faire entendre la voix
du peuple iranien de la jeunesse
iranienne les actes symboliques sont
importants sont très importants mais
sont loin d'être suffisants et vous
parlez à des gens j'imagine en Iran
qu'est-ce qu'il vous disent est-ce
qu'ils sont prêts à aller jusqu'au bout
cette fois combien de temps ça va durer
ou est-ce que ça va s'essouffler à cause
de la répression qui est très forte ce
régime est capable de commettre des
pires crimes pour garder le pouvoir
parce que c'était un régime par essence
criminel donc vous n'êtes pas très
optimiste question n'est pas optimiste
ou pessimiste c'est que sans aide
significative des pays démocratiques
je ne pense pas que on puisse renverser
ce régime et vous est-ce que vous
regrettez de ne pas être aux côtés de
tous ces jeunes qui manifestent il
m'arrive de parfois à me dire peut-être
que je vais entrer en Iran et me battre
à côté ou en tout cas aider parce que
voilà de pouvoir faire quelque chose
concrètement sur place mais dans notre
côté il faut aussi à l'extérieur des
gens qui savent réfléchir penser aider
et amener les
faire entendre la voix aussi entendre la
voix mais aussi faire agir les pays
démocratiques et aussi si je rentre en
Iran et bien on arrêtera et je serai
tout de suite en prison et torturé donc
ça m'aide pas vraiment et je pense que
si je n'avais pas quitté l'Iran j'aurais
été déjà exécuté au moins 10 fois depuis
25 ans j'écris j'essaye de sensibiliser
l'opinion publique en France et dans les
pays où mes livres ont été produit
ce n'est pas grand chose c'est déjà
beaucoup on travaille le plus essentiel
et fait par des jeunes à l'intérieur du
pays
beaucoup de gens au Canada là il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont très actifs
donc
mais on a vraiment besoin de l'aide
significative des pays démocratiques
merci pour ce témoignage merci
absolument